the tea bio info platform was developed
at the Taliban fanatics Research Center
at University of Haifa in Israel it is
now commercialized by pine biotech aus
big data analytics company that has been
growing over the past several years
through numerous research collaborations
innovative data-driven solutions and
products for research and education the
platform offers a streamlined process
from learning to the application of
bioinformatics in all life sciences
it is designed for those seeking to make
sense of the big molecular datasets
coming from next-generation sequencing
and wanting to leverage computational
advances for processing analysis and
integration of big data
we believe that bioinformatics literacy
is key across all stages of data
generation processing and utilization in
critical decisions making it an
essential skill for lab technicians
researchers and clinicians our vision is
to make bioinformatics accessible and
useful without unnecessary complications
that exclude non experts and make
conventional tasks extremely burdensome
to make bound from Attucks accessible
and effective for anyone the T bio info
is an alternative to buggy open-source
solutions expensive commercial tools
that requires specialized computing
hardware and experts that are difficult
to find and hard to interact with it is
an intuitive platform that combines big
data analysis with a simple and
intuitive interface it is guided by an
intelligent process that prevents even a
beginner from major mistakes that
rendered analysis ineffective the key to
our solution is a user-friendly
consistent interface across key data
types utilities and analytical methods
on the platform you can find sections
organized by data type like
next-generation sequencing mass
spectroscopy struck
data and others run analysis or play
around with demo pipelines learn about
visualization statistical analysis and
machine learning find previous pipelines
you have run or monitor the ones you are
using right now and see your account
information with data and research
projects you are working on the
pipeline's crunching big data do not
require even a single line of code the
platform allows for large scale analysis
from a web interface that anyone can
learn to use as a result researchers can
fully integrate analysis into their
research taking sample data and
integrating it with repositories that
they have collected and already trust
the pipeline builder remains flexible
offering intuitive suggestions and
enriching the process with informative
pop-ups and assisting with reproducible
research at the file data and visual
levels the front-end pipelines can be
easily monitored and edited by an expert
that can deploy a redundant tasks at
scale leveraging efficient big data
processing capabilities behind the
scenes the analytical capacity of the
t-bone 4 platform allows the users to
work with sequence structure and
molecules at the bulk or even single
cell level discovering complex
relationships by following a logical
transition from single to multi-omics
data where genomics epigenomics
metagenomics proteomics and metabolomics
can be analyzed to reveal a systems
biology view of phenotype genotype
relationships spanning diverse and
heterogeneous data sources from patient
derived cell lines to xenograft models
and clinical trials the platform vision
originated from dr. Lena Brodsky who has
extensive academic and commercial
experience with both biostatistics and
bioinformatics behind the vision there
is an experienced team that is working
on
aspects of the platform
commercialization and growth and
expansion to address research questions
that are being solved by cutting-edge
researchers around the world the company
is based at the bio Innovation Center in
New Orleans and is working closely with
a number of collaborators from various
US and international institutions